I remember Ben Stiller and I we went and
we had dinner with Mick Jagger because
early in Ben's career we got bad I'm
jealous oh oh no I totally ruined it
we're writing a script about the Rolling
Stones called and said hey will you do
it's a movie it's a concert movie but in
between there's comedy and a little
story this is one better cheesy yeah
exactly
it's a terrible idea I'm so glad but Ben
this is right after the Ben Stiller show
was cancelled he wasn't really famous
yet and he wanted to do it with Brad
Pitt and Brad Pitt wasn't famous either
we like this Brad Pitt guy from Thelma
and Louise right so subtly Ben and I are
talking to Mick Jagger all the time
about this script I Mick Jagger by the
way only wants to be a movie star and
wants to direct movies and stuff like
that yeah
and he's super nice we're doing phone
calls with him I'm recording every phone
call right and then you tell him that of
course not your sneaky guy because I
know that there's no way this is gonna
really work out right and I and on my
computer every time I screwed up the
alerts I made it a sample of Mick Jagger
so if I mess up on my computer it would
go that's funny and then we went had
dinner and I couldn't talk Wow for an
hour I just I didn't say a word I kept
looking at me like and then finally I
was trying to find a way to relate to
him and I'm like yeah I go on the road
crazy I know there are certain people
you just can't pull it together and and
I would imagine Mick Jagger I always
wanted to interview Mick Jagger I mean
that I in fact you need ten hours at
least to make a dent in that life now we
have to pitch the whole band the movie
ah so it's been and I have to go and
pitch the entire Rolling Stones now all
the jokes are about like Keith Richards
having his blood replaced like addiction
jokes and the mythology of the band
jokes and so Ben says okay I'm gonna
pitch and I'm like okay I'm gonna try
in your the chiming in guy bands the
pitch guy yeah I'm gonna throw in some
jokes yeah and so Ben starts pitching it
and I totally lock up just looking right
at us and I'm just quite intimidating
right he's too cool for the room it's
terrifying
yeah and Ben starts pitching and Ben's
like hey so let's so we're gonna do it
let's do it like kind of Gimme Shelter
style you know that kind of
cinematography and Keith Richards goes
yes but this time let's do it without
the murder and then Ron Wood kept like
raising his hand going gets a partial
vote yeah he came in late to the stones
going okay why didn't you direct it to
Alfred Hitchcock because Ron Wood was so
enthusiastic and he kept annoying Keith
Richards so I think we should do it and
he's like okay Brian Jones fun of Brian
Jones poor bastard so you know we
finished the the pitch and then we walk
out of the room and now we're like at
the door right next to where they're
debating it right Ben wants to listen to
them debate it like they're like go
downstairs but Ben's at the door and I'm
like Ben Keith Richards will stab us
right we can't do this so we go
downstairs it said like a gym in Toronto
they're like practicing for the tour at
Hague High School we go downstairs and
then Ron what just gives us a thumbs-up
like you're in wow like we're gonna do
it at shitty pitch exactly yeah and then
we sit down and they're like hey you can
watch us rehearse so in this little room
we watch the stones perform just for Ben
and me oh my god like two and a half
hours Wow oh my god and it was
unbelievable and in the middle of it
everyone said oh hell Mick Jagger would
walk over and go you guys okay you need
some water oh are you alright it was and
I kept saying the bed is the best mom
forget this moment this won't happen
again and then ultimately it fell apart
because Brad Pitt got this other movie
se7en you know though but but what's so
amazing like I've interviewed been a
bunch of times and I've interviewed you
and like that to you guys like that's a
may just that would be the major story
of my life I could stop living that
tonight and you guys you have so many
experiences that you probably have even
sort of filed that away somewhere and
never even told that it that's not true
that's the best story I tell in a lot
well I I didn't know at the time like oh
this is crazy